welcome to the program we begin in
France where the president has held a
crisis meeting after two days of violent
protests across the country the growing
anger was triggered by the Fatal police
shooting of a 17 year old driver on
Tuesday
Emmanuel macron called the unrest
unjustifiable as he opened the meeting
with senior ministers thousands of
police have been deployed in various
districts
thank you
that meeting came after a second night
of violence at least 150 people were
arrested the unrest has spread to
multiple cities across France with
protesters targeting Town Halls schools
and police stations dozens of officers
have been injured and the government's
again calling for calm
Natasha Butler was in non-tier as the
unrest continued
well we're in the neighborhood where
Noel came from in the Paris suburb of
nonte and some young people have been
out on the streets they've been uh
firing fireworks at police officers
police officers who have created a line
here across this road and behind you
could see a number of cars are on fire
they've been settled by the police are
now moving in we don't quite know why
but obviously this is a situation that
they'll want to control uh fast many
residents in this area had hoped that
they wouldn't be more violence there was
violence already on Tuesday night after
the shooting of this teenager but nearly
everyone we spoke to here Sony
understands the anger that has
younger amongst this neighborhood this
community that has been so shaken by the
death of this teenager during this
[Music]